quel jalel harchaoui chercheurs aux
clients dell institute de la javel
harchaoui merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors le gouvernement d'union
nationale on le disait a rejeté
aujourd'hui la très voulu par le général
haftar pendant le mois de ramadan
c'était prévisible
oui c'était prévisible qu'il qu'il
demande un cessez-le-feu ou au moment où
justement ces difficultés commencent à
devenir réellement aiguë et est
difficile à affronter
et c'est aussi prévisible que dans ces
moments où où les landes une escalade
qui est prévu par la turquie depuis
quatre mois
évidemment on ne peut pas être arrêtée
maintenant donc c'est une espèce de
valse à laquelle on assiste avec ce mot
clé de pause humanitaire ou de cessez le
feu mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
véritablement mais table en oeuvre ni
d'un côté ni de l'autre
haftar ne peut pas réellement arrêter
ces hommes en tripolitaine le l'élan est
juste trop grand et ça n'aurait eu ça ne
répond à aucun réalisme ce genre de ce
que la raison pour laquelle je pense que
c'est prévisible c'est parce qu'il en a
besoin il a besoin d'un cessez le feu
pour retrouver ses forces
robes et ses hommes accumulé un peu plus
d'équipements qu'ils attendent notamment
de la part des émirats arabes unis
peut-être récolter des mercenaires
supplémentaires qu'ils essaient
d'obtenir depuis plusieurs semaines et
c'est pour cela qu'il demande un cessez
le feu c'est aussi une occasion pour
crier à quel point on peut diaboliser
comme ça la turquie et le gouvernement
d'entente nationale
c'est un jeu cela veut dire que quand le
général tard promet une réponse très
rude et immédiate en cas de violation de
cette trêve par le le gn à ce que vous
nous dites c'est que finalement il n'a
pas les moyens de de cette riposte rude
et immédiate il n'a pas les moyens de
jade d'arrêter les hostilités même de
son côté à lui d'ailleurs ne sont pas
arrêtées pendant toutes les les annonces
ce qu'on entend depuis hier les
hostilités de la part de ses amants
continuer et on comprend parce qu'ils
sont coincés dans des situations qui ne
sont pas
stable et évidemment les hommes du
gouvernement d'entendre nationale
continuent leur opération ils vont pas
s'arrêter maintenant alors que ça fait
des mois et des mois qu'ils y
travaillent des millions d'euros qui ont
été dépensés pour justement la mise en
place de cette france de cette contre
offensive de tripoli le fait de menacer
le gouvernement d'entente nationale en
cas de non respect du cessez le feu oui
vous avez raison c'est absolument
absurde parce que il c'est quelqu'un qui
en difficulté militaire je ne dis pas
qu'il est en train de s'écrouler
je ne dis pas que c'est fini pour lui
mais il sa situation est inquiétante et
c'est pour cela qu'on a assisté à cette
prise de pouvoir il ya quelques jours
dans l'est de la libye ce parce qu'il se
sent en danger il a peur qu'on le
remplace
il a peur que des états comme la russie
se met à parler de plus en plus à
d'autres figures de l'est de la libye de
la cyrénaïque et qu'il perdrait comme ça
tout toute valeur politique qui le
sombrerait dans l'oubli ça c'est un
risque qu'il a réussi à réduire en
faisant de l'ordre en éclipsant les
institutions civiles qui existaient qui
l'ont soutenue au cours de cette demi
décennie depuis 2015 2014
elle ne soutiennent mais c'est à cause
de ces difficultés là qui s'est senti
menacé qu'il a dû prendre un peu plus de
pouvoir effacer donc les quelques
institutions civiles qui existait à
l'est
oui pourquoi en cure il nous reste très
peu de temps à haut niveau international
on disait la russie qui était soutien du
général haftar a pris ses distances
mardi dernier en affirmant ne pas
approuver la verdad sa déclaration selon
laquelle il décidera unilatéralement est
la façon dont le peuple libyen
vivre à cette prise de position de la
russie peut être changer la donne oui la
russie par ce cas là la force si vous
voulez la force du réaliste la force de
caractère de d'une entité tout à fait
réaliste et qui ne se prend pas au jeu
idéologique des uns et des autres à la
possibilité comme ça et c'est ce à quoi
on assiste assez frappant de dire que
haftar est un acteur qui doit se prêter
aux conditions de ses parents et le
parent peut être le plus important dans
cette a7 à ce moment charnière
c'est la russie qui peut effectivement
changé de camp elle peut moduler son
soutien elle peut retirer certains
soutiens militaires certains soutiens
économiques mêmes qui sont assez vitaux
pour le maraîcher riveta et toute cette
marge de manoeuvre ni les états ni la
france ni les émirats arabes unis non ce
type de marge de manoeuvre dont c'est
assez frappant maire de voir le réalisme
de poutine à l'oeuvre merci beaucoup
jaoui d'avoir partager votre avis je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur au
exigeant d'elle institute de l'ain